thank
[Applause]
you I like these people and Airhead gov
shows a tater love true wretch and
Gretchen went from a kidnapping hoax to
making horrible potato jokes our video
of the day comes to us from Michigan's
Gretchen Whitmer who announced news
about higher education with the help of
a talking potato roll it hey Governor
Whitmer how's it going hi professor
potato I wanted to share some Yukon Gold
news with you my best SP what is it we
both agree that every michigander
deserves an opportunity to go to college
without frying their bank account
absolutely a higher education helps you
learn more skills pursue your passions
and even plant your roots right here in
Michigan I think we found out where
Brian stelter's
been
now got a
tan he won't be any beauty pageants all
right now you might be thinking am I
high on mushrooms but no this is a real
video released by a sitting Governor so
what's going on Whitmer is acting more
baked than that
potato but I guess if you want to tell
taxpayers that they're footing the bill
for even more useless crap you might as
well use a
potato seriously if a potato inspires
you to go to college maybe you should
just start practicing the question do
you want fries with
that more
please but for too many college is
financially Out Of Reach that's why I'm
so excited to announce an appealing plan
oh I know what you're planning this year
we will work together to make the first
two years of Community College tuition
free for every high school graduate
that's right Professor michiganders will
save an average of
$4,000 as they earn their associates
degree hey that isn't Small Potatoes
that's a big deal to learn more make
sure you tune in for my State of the
State address I'll be there for sure
sure later tater later
tater am I still think I'm
hi and I thought Whitmer was only bad at
politics nice job Michigan you elected a
woman who talks to side dishes you don't
see tutor Dixon chatting with a dish of
cold slaw or coold slaw but that's
democrats for you a governor who talks
to starches and a president who's a
vegetable nice cat as a native
michigander is that how you say
michigander michigander yeah michigander
how do you explain this okay well we do
sketches on this show sometimes yes if
somebody came to me with a script and I
looked down and it said I've got some
Yukon Gold news for you you're my best
Spud like I wouldn't do it right I would
also say who on the staff has a problem
with me yeah I'd prefer you just tell me
directly right her girl your staff hates
hates
you there's no way anybody could have
watched it like wrote this and be like
this is going to look good yeah
everybody that works for her hates her
because this would have not gotten
through any other way this is
humiliating and you could have told you
could have known to be humiliating so
you people hate you sorry it's tough
it's tough to hear but I'll be the one
to tell you since no one El will she
needs a she needs a best friend so don't
do the potato thing yeah don't do the
potato thing tyus and that wasn't even
an appetizing potato usually a I love
potatoes I'm just curious was Idaho
aware of this cultural
robbery anyone fromel a potato yeah I
was like whoa listen this is what
happens when uh you don't check what
your staff is up to yeah she didn't see
the the graphics they said hey we got
this really cool thing it's going to be
this it's going to be like Sesame Street
and you're going to talk to a potato
she's like like a potato puppet like
yeah kind of and uh it's like the dude
with the upside head it doesn't even
look like a potato looks like some sick
furry thing um a caterpillar maybe but
whatever it is it's terrible and she
didn't see it because she was lazy she
wouldn't go to the studio she did it on
her phone yeah so she has no idea what
she's talking about or whom she's
talking to or what technology is
involved she just saw when it was done
yeah yeah it's fine it's fine then when
it hit the thing one of her staffers was
like did you see the thing you just did
and she was like yeah it can't be the oh
my God how do we get of this like this
is what happens you got to double check
St that's why you check everything
before it comes on air most of the time
who is the potato I really I'm dying
yeah I want to look at that potato you
know how a mustache looks like it's a
guy with a mustache you know what it
reminds me of Hunter's
penis been through a lot people by the
way she did Miss A pun there he could
have said hey what do you do for a
living and she can go I had a hoe
yeah it's a pun people I don't really
mean that uh
the only way this works is if the potato
tries to kidnap her that's the only way
this
works a bunch of fries come up behind
her you know it's like let's go the
potato could be an undercover fed yes
fed fed fed fed fed fed all right uh lee
uh you can do potato puns if you want or
you can address what is wrong with our
Governors so when I was running for for
governor I was trying to working hard to
connect with Gen Z and Millennial voters
and I had no idea that this is what
they're looking for a governor who
spends their day talking to a potato I
never realized that and first off it's a
creepy ass potato to tyrus's point you
have you have to address that but like
seriously who who does this relate to
yeah I I mean other than Brian stelter
yeah the target audience of this
particular video I can't name anyone who
is watching this and saying yeah it's
like it's likees it's like for babies or
something it's like a Barney video this
is not for people going to college it's
it's warped it's strange I I'm worried
about her this is impeachable and she
she's trying and she it's a tease to
watch her State of the State address who
what what Sesame Street Viewer is going
to watch this and then tune into to her
address but I I uh I was impressed that
you went with the uh Brian stelter thing
that was was that was a lwh hanging
tuber yes it was um but uh no but this
is what the funniest thing about all
this she's supposed to be the smart one
yeah this comes out as the that book
came out that that the Biden didn't want
to pick Cala Harris at all in the first
place he wanted to pick her yes and it's
like so she's the smart one there's it's
like where do we go from here well don't
worry about that she's going to get sued
because people who identify as potatoes
are going to be Furious that they had a
keyboard and a laptop there knowing that
potatoes don't have hands so you're just
rubbing it in his face that he's a
vegetable without a posable thumb so
she's got enough problems to deal with
right there because the potato whes the
potato iters they're going to be furious
when they they will well all eyes will
be on you
Governor eyes very appealing potatoes
have eyes did you know that which is
weird cuz you live underground but I
know makes no sense that's why he knows
yeah oh wow up next is The Daily Show
toast with a recycled host hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else